as the eponymous host of the Greg
Gutfeld show which airs Saturday
evenings on Fox News co-host of that
same network's hugely popular afternoon
talk show the five tonight and creator
of the defunct path-breaking late night
show redeye Greg Gutfeld is one of the
most ubiquitous presences on cable news
a prolific writer and former editor of
maximun stuff magazines Gutfeld has a
new book out the gutfeld monologues
classic rants from the five reason sat
down with the libertarian leaning
conservative to talk about his new book
punk rock and just how great it would be
if Rosie O'Donnell challenged Donald
Trump in the 2020 election hi I'm Nick
Gillespie with reason and I am sitting
down with Greg Gutfeld the co-host of
the five and I guess you have something
to do with the Greg Gutfeld show yes it
was named after me okay but other than
that that's why some that I'm not
nothing to do with it okay yeah it's
just an imposter your new book is the
Gutfeld monologues classic rants from
the five beyond the paycheck what what
prompted this and what is that what's
what's the elevator pitch for why people
should read the ramp because people who
watch the five we're asking for a like a
place where they could find the
monologues and I kept getting asked that
question all over so I just thought well
this is a really easy project I'll just
collect them all and put them in one
spot you described in the opening of the
book your big mistake about Trump and
Trump selection I'll tell that story I
was like 99% of everybody in media who
just assumed he was gonna be shellacked
I was told that day by experts that by
nine o'clock he would be conceding
that's it Wow America who really did it
this time and you know it's good when
the media is losing their while this was
going on I had ignored people who
weren't in the media who were my close
friends I have a buddy who's a cop I
have a buddy who runs a steakhouse
Westside steak house down on 10th if
you're there where do we get a coupon
yes this kind of steaks aren't quite
good it's was there bacon but he would
always say don't count the guy out Greg
kept saying that his name's Nick and my
buddy's a cop would say the same thing I
have like a nozzle you have a cab driver
I have a group of regular people you
have the village people worry I'll have
to dress in uniform when I talk to them
let's bring the police officer and he
does a little dance you know but my
point is I was ignoring everybody
including my friends from college in
California and I was just like you don't
know you don't work you don't understand
what this is like he's gonna win but
that day obvious I had this little New
York Times well it's on my phone that
app that showed the percentage that
Hillary would win like right yeah it was
the confidence ratio or something like
she was gonna win
she had 90 percent yeah interval or
whatever so I was sitting that I had to
do a 5 at the 5 o'clock and then another
one around midnight or something and so
I went to this bar and I had like it was
at like 95 percent and I was talking to
the bouncer one of the one of my regular
friends the bouncer you know and he was
he said wonder what are the odds and I
said oh she's got it in the bag and he
just became just straw like distraught
anyway as I was sitting at the bar I
just kept noticing this app changing and
I was going well now it's at 80% now
it's at 70% and I'm starting to get a
little bit weirded out because were you
gonna say you were getting worried
because that meant you were gonna have
to sober up and go back on TV or
something yeah actually I only had one
glass of wine and I maintained that I
was worried because I didn't know what
to think from a personal level how what
happens when you're completely wrong
like what's the what's the world is a
new world for you you've never been
wrong and it is like my god this is a
big but everybody was wrong except for
maybe five people and like I say in the
book I'm not even sure that President
Trump thought he wouldn't thought he was
gonna win so the whole that whole
chapter is about coming to terms with
his this earthquake it was really
probably one of the most momentous
political upheavals I think I've lived
through you talk critically about Trump
but also you really hate people who hate
Trump yeah what is your relationship
with him because then he also was a
guest or he was in a sketch that opened
the Greg Gutfeld show yeah well how did
that happen
he was very friendly before he ever was
running he used you have to understand
there's something that unites
interesting people and it's watching
redeye you were a fan of redeye
so was Donald Trump yeah people that
were up late at night recovering
alcoholics or alcoholics breastfeeding
mothers meth-heads truck drivers college
kids not college kids any you name it
they were reunited by this really weird
show and Donald Trump watched it I mean
he didn't just watch it he knew the show
so he would he called me up a couple of
times about red eye and he'd tell me how
funny it was and he knew all the players
like everything from Bill - Andy - then
Joanne and so he ended up I very nice my
show up and he we did a segment where I
interviewed him about whether he would
run for president and then I jokingly
was auditioning to be his press
secretary it was a joke
we've heard these rumors that you might
run for president and I was wondering if
you do and you win what would be my role
well I think you'd be a fantastic press
secretary you know would finally have a
little personality in that position yeah
I remember I asked him I go are you are
you really good this was off-camera yeah
I said are you gonna run he goes Greg I
can't tell you I can't tell you anything
but when it happens when it happens
you're not gonna see anything like it
you're not gonna see anything like it I
mean it's going to be it's good it's
just gonna be amazing and he was right I
mean I didn't know what he meant like
yeah I mean he was like in his head he
knew that something was gonna break when
he was gonna do it and and it was I just
didn't actually really didn't believe
him cuz he said it before hidden room he
talked about running a lot yeah and he
mm yeah it was a party Pro yeah Russ
pros / they reform partiers Jesse
Ventura something like that so what do
you cannon what is your attitude towards
Trump because in the in in the Millat of
the monologues are about how you know
people hate Trump and they become
deranged by you know or Trump
derangement syndrome but do you like him
do you dislike him like what is your
sense of what's your sense I've come to
understand him as kind of as a character
and a character whose words
are cheap in the way that my words are
cheap and that I talk a lot and he talks
a lot so his opinions like his opinions
are his opinions and he'll change them
and and what happens with I think with
the media and then and the viral and the
angry anti Trump errs is that they see
everything he says as somehow an attempt
to do something like like so this is the
I think it was a reporter named Selena
Zito who said that Trump's critics take
him literally but not seriously his his
admirers take him seriously but not
literal and I would say that as a critic
I was in that camp so once he became
elected I switched like I I decided okay
he's now the president I'm gonna focus
solely on deeds and let his look I
continue to get mad over his words but
I'm gonna like brick crack a rib
you know I'm - you can't be outraged
every day it's like if you have an uncle
that comes over and says rude things and
you and you stand you've known him for
40 years and you still get upset that's
on you you just have to like you just
have to live with it so what are what
are the deeds that he's done that you
you like I like well the first thing I
have to say was the the climate change
getting out of that the Accords not
because I'm a I don't believe in climate
change I just didn't believe in that
deal and I think you know one of the
things he said was it was a lousy deal I
think he he believes in climate change
but I don't know I mean I don't want to
mind-read but he just knew that that was
a lousy deal and there's people like
well who does the Copenhagen consensus
yarn love your network like he'll talk
about how it takes like 30 trillion to
solve all the world's problems
but the hundred trillion for the climate
Accords would would move well would keep
Celsius from everything like that so it
was this like such a it was such a not a
scam but a terrible deal so I thought
that was really really good I'm into the
deregulation stuff I you know the
Supreme Court I'm fine with those are
just things and so I and also it's I
think it's in his heart he's a pacifist
I don't I mean he's he's he's not he
doesn't strike me as somebody who wants
to waste blood and treasure
but I could be wrong I don't know yet so
I can run before in this interview next
so I've been wrong just I have being in
your presence I've been wrong I'm
already regretting talking to you what
I'm regretting setting this up myself
where we have that account with regret
he speaks highly of people like the
police in a way that you know change
things what do you mean by that well he
saw in opening and I think it was oh
wait maybe he was always this way but
they would I call it the stool turn
remember what it was this the stool of
security which was like national
security law and order in borders and
they all kind of go together as like a
safer world and so he could in anybody
for that to work you have to have the
antithesis so he was coming in after I'd
say three or four years of some serious
police bashing on other networks in
which they looked at brutality as not a
bug in the system but the system itself
so when you saw a case of something
horrible happening which we had seen
that net all police were bad and all it
took was a politician and I was doing
this on the five a lot which is what
this is not a system this is a bug in
the system and you'd get these really
sobering statistics that were even in
the Washington Post in New York Times
about how misleading the media was about
police shootings and they found that
some in some cases some police officers
are more likely to shoot than others and
it was like it went against the
narrative that they were pushing out I
think that gave gave an opening did a
couple of things like that look at not
being able to say radical Islam might be
a small ball for a lot of people but it
would it was an opening to say I'm gonna
say it radical Islam and everybody goes
finally somebody saying it and not
calling it workplace violence so that
was an opening and the national security
thing what's wrong with what's wrong
with having a border I mean what's wrong
with have it you know build a wall like
that was an open I mean that's I think
the opening do you know what I mean yeah
yeah so it wasn't necessarily whether
you agree with him or not but he could
sense that all things to get all these
things together kind of made this
persona how much do you think it was him
and I mean you know he also I mean he
created it's it's incredible that he
want I mean I think everybody has to
admit that
this guy has like no [ __ ] place being
you know doing this and he pulled it off
a lot of it was that the reason isn't
that what should not make you happy yeah
oh yeah no no I mean I like I know place
he showed that the the two-party system
is kind of a joke yeah but it's also he
ran against Hillary Clinton how how
important was that and what do you do
now when you're you know you're at the
five you have your own show foxes
I wouldn't say is objectively Pro Trump
but it's Trump friendly out of the cable
networks right and you don't have
Hillary Clinton around to bash anymore
but you know what's amazing is that
we're doing today was we taped this
interview a segment on Hillary and
Chelsea because Chelsea's talking about
running and Hillary's getting back
involved to do fundraising they aren't
away and I loved I love that they're
around and that's that is a I mentioned
that in the book that she's like she's
you know constantly being moved around
and it's like the more she's around
because I need to have something fun you
know just to lampoon and and and she
provides so much in for me there's so
much fodder and so I don't think she's
going away and by the way I argue and no
one listens to me the same way Rocky two
was anticipated Hillary Trump to a
rematch would be the biggest political
event in history and all the people who
didn't vote for Hillary because they
thought she had in the bag would be out
in force and be like you know be like
with brexit I try to remember the plot
to rock you know I might be a terrible
analogy with Apollo Creed yeah it had to
be against Apollo Creed anyway but then
it was rocky 3 where he takes on mr. t
right and and Apollo Creed is training
him clubber Lang the it was probably an
awful analogy but sequels this sequel so
it's like The Godfather
yes Godfather which won the Best Picture
yeah yeah and it like I think the
Democrats hate Hillary so much they
won't give her the chance because you
yeah the comparison would be when you
hear about the people who didn't vote
during the brexit thing now saying we
want another vote so we can vote that's
kind of what this would be but aren't
you I mean you are what are you like 54
55 something like that I'm in my early
thirties okay I'm sorry you know it's
it's the body parts that have been
pleasure liver is an oscillating dude
the wisdom of a man mid-century what
aren't you aren't you disgusted by the
idea that it's gonna be you would have
an election with to like 75 euros it's
crazy it's crazy but it's a Joe Biden
yeah he's still around Elizabeth Warren
never years old isn't it weird that
those are only choices how about it's
like even the Soviets at the end we're
like putting in 50 years yeah you know
me okay you know I I think it's a theory
in the book but I can't remember if it's
in the book or not the reason why Trump
one was this contrast theory like you
had 17 similars and one that stood out
even Carly Fiorina Fiorini Fiorina
blend it in even as a woman blend it in
with the rest and Rand Paul is different
blend it in with the rest but you had
like 17th politicians in one guy I think
that's gonna happen with the Democrats
they're gonna have I hope my hands are
clean yeah I read rode the subway so I
didn't realize you have six fingers yeah
it's amazing isn't it amazing what I can
do with that second finger but anyway so
you have Democrats could have could have
a dozen people and you could have the
Komaki you'd have Kamala Harris
you could have Liz Warren Joe Biden but
then you could have like an outlier and
I'm not gonna think I'm joking when I
say Mark Ruffalo or even Rosie O'Donnell
I say Rosie O'Donnell I would because
people laugh at Trump but think about
Rosie reality show talk show conspiracy
mm-hmm outspoken and I think kind of
funny yeah um well she'll take it she'll
take it to Trump in a way yeah that that
was part of the problem with the
Republicans England I mean Jeb Bush like
I think he started to cry when it was
when Trump was like you're Low Energy
how do you deal with it it's like I'm
Brandt you just branded me and I can't
unbranded you had Mario attempting to
mimic Trump and and it just made Mario
look small area Mart Marco Rubio boy how
long have I forgotten about him yeah
Mario Mario Mario Cuomo Mario Cuomo
yesterday
Marco Rubio who was my actually my first
choice really yes why because he's short
yes we both should stick together any
other
yeah he had a boat I like people any
metrosexual they have the Cuban heel
boots I did I was the editor of men's
health yeah so maybe he was just like a
subscriber I I realized that he was
still kind of a politician like
everybody else I talked to a Shapiro I
did and he's like he was Ted Cruz all
the way right Ted Cruz but do you think
Ted Cruz would have been ridiculed even
any less any lesser the Trump know he
would he was would be supremely
punchable for a liberal they would have
gone after him I gotta tell you right
now if Ted Cruz was pretty punchable or
a libertarian I think for just about
everybody on the political side the
other day anyway we rested my point is
we say that that Trump was the most
vulnerable candidate and I believe that
and that's why Hillary thought it was
funny and CNN thought it was funny to
prop him up but look how they treated
Mitt Romney they treated him awful they
treated John McCain awful they would
have eaten I think Marco alive on his
pro-life stance and Ted Cruz would have
offered Saturday Night Live endless so I
think Trump actually looking back on it
2020 is was like the most battle ready
for any 16 Twitter no I mean I think Oh
20/20 hindsight okay that's so part one
at one of the sections of the book I'm
thinking about Rosie O'Donnell and us
has spent a lot of time talking about
Alec Baldwin who's kind of gone missing
and that's kind of a loss for public
discourse Hollywood is integral to like
your theory of why Trump was you know
became a viable alternative discuss that
the less you know about something the
more strongly you feel about something
and so you have a group of people in
Hollywood that have spent a lot of time
apolitical looking out for themselves
and their career is becoming famous and
all of a sudden they reach a point in
their lives where they wonder if they're
intellectually irrelevant like you know
and suddenly they started looking at
causes and they really believe it like
Leo DiCaprio and the environment but but
the issue is they're kind of at the high
school level at that point in politics
and so they have the passion they have
the sincere passion but they don't have
the wisdom and the more passion they
have the less wisdom they have so
they're almost entirely wrong on
everything
now that they lost that all they have is
that passion and they are angry and
they're broken they mean it is one big
that election was one big trigger event
do you think regular Americans dislike
Hollywood or do they like it I mean is
it because you know we consume more and
more entertainment but then is that the
same thing as Hollywood and what's the
disconnect there because and the reason
I'm bringing this up is you mentioned in
the book I mean you were tight with
Andrew Breitbart who is famous for
saying that politics is downstream from
culture so how does this work because we
on a certain level are watching more
entertainment than ever yeah but it
seems that people hate Hollywood more
than more and more maybe it's that thing
where you love video games but you don't
know anything about the video game
companies you know and maybe that's
where we are with Hollywood a good
example the VMAs were Sunday night it
used to be for shows like red eye and
the 5 and Fox News and this was like you
could do like three segments on it and
I'm talking like 10 years ago and
wouldn't I worked in magazines I used to
go to these things and they were a big
deal you saw it the biggest stars now
it's like there was no hype there's no
buzz it came and what I didn't even know
it was on until I looked on Twitter and
it said VMAs what was trending and I
turned it on and it was just like it was
like pantomiming the VMAs from 15 years
ago it was as though they were
historical re-enactors of pop culture it
was meaningless and I think that's also
a healthy sign we don't find them
interesting you're seeing numbers go
down for the Oscars and I think I think
the numbers for the VMAs must be at
there and yet am i right to think that
you at times are topping like Real Time
with Bill Maher I don't look at their
numbers but we're number one on Saturday
evenings more than anybody in the demo
my theory and the demo boom what's it 18
to 54 something like that I think I love
that by not because 18 year olds in 54
year old exactly like yeah they do they
all want the same thing exactly some of
them do sadly in Hollywood that is
usually the 50 year old once the 18 year
old well you know I thought we had
stipulated we're not
talking about Asia Argento at all oh my
god crazy stuff the five was a mid like
summer replacement yeah right and they
were trying to figure out what to Glenn
Beck Glenn Beck left and so like why is
the five popular I have my theories but
it's improvisational conversation
between people who like each other the
more you and me yes but there is but
everybody has to actually if if somebody
is on there because we're obviously
having different people on there now
with talking points and they are talking
abouts and they kind of look at the
camera uh no you got to beat this
conversation but my number one thing
that I think that the reason why the
five worked and why red I worked I mean
Gigi she is teasing you got to be if you
don't like somebody you can't tease them
and so the like the wide the five took
office because I was sitting there
teasing Dana almost every day Kimberly
was teasing me
bob was teasing Eric there was all this
team it was just like it's not what you
saw in a normal show people and
obviously with red eye I mean Bill
Schulz was the repulsive sidekick he was
the punching bag and Andy levy the
libertarian would come in and like
admonished me for being a right-wing hat
why did well two things and obviously
red I survived when you moved on with
Tom Slough before he killed it yeah well
you know he's got that touch he's the
Mengele of late-night-tv right but you
know why didn't why didn't any other
network replicate redeye and also the
white fox seemed to undersell it like
they should have been rerunning it so
much more it because it did really well
and it was a real unique show
I think people tried tried it but they
couldn't figure out the secret which was
chemistry and teasing like and also was
the reason why people Buell I know you
liked it and I mean it was weird I was
so disappointed when I finally got to be
on it I was so disappointed that it
wasn't taped at like 3 o'clock in the
morning that struck me is the most
magical thing it's the weirdest show I
think like I go back to maybe Fernwood
tonight as a weird show that like how
did this happen because right I did you
didn't think I didn't think about how it
was happening but we just kept adding
like subversive touches whether there
was a
that's interested in unicorns who
shouldn't be weird stories about house
boys and then you had like Andy and his
cats and Bill just dragged in through
the God knows where on the back of a cab
you know and it was just such a weird it
was a you universe and we did so many
weird things I think that the reason why
I was under sold is that nobody was
watching it on the like most people at
Fox we're not watching and except the
overnight crew but I don't think you
know I would say like maybe you know
today saw 10 episodes out of the facet
how are things at Fox because there's
been you know I mean but beyond the
resignation or the Roger Ailes being
forced out with the change in leadership
in various a lot of personnel changes
how did that affect like what were you
aware of kind of the sexual issues going
on and then like is the morale there
upbeat or downbeat I think that it's
like in recovery which is a weird weird
phrase to put it but it's like it was
such an unusual time and it prepped it
prefaced what happened late in
everywhere else do you know what I mean
with uh with the Weinstein stuff I do it
happened it just happened to us first
and I think it was jarring and I think
if you you know you know I can't get
into the details but it was fairly it
was fairly surreal and it's sometimes
just sad and then but now when you look
back and you see that 70% or 75% of the
75 3 of the 4 nighttime shows are gone I
think and it our ratings have never been
better and and that is to me a testament
to the resiliency of the company but
also the resiliency of the fans that the
fans stuck bias and didn't go up that's
it I'm out of here
you guys suck no they're like I go and I
do these book tours and there are people
that are just you know they love talker
you know they love the changes and and
so that's important I mean there are
people that go that you know what
happened but at the same time it's like
well this and also it's 20 years it's
been it's been 20 years there's a lot of
changes that have that happened in that
time it just seems like it happened a
lot in one time what are you finding on
campuses
I'm book tours as it relates to
college-age kids I think they're being
unfairly maligned as being cheap or just
toting the the left wing line there's a
lot more than I've ever seen who are
just independent thinkers a lot of
libertarians a lot of kids for that fine
Trump interesting but they also find the
hole they've also learned more about the
system there's more of people like me
when I was young than I've ever seen
like people that just think it's
hilarious what went into you as and I
realized you did go to Catholic school
so it probably has something to do with
the priest but now what went into you as
a make up to you know when you look at
your Oracle do you you know you're you
were conservative somewhat you know with
some libertarian flavors you're into
punk and pop music and stuff where did
that come from and why do you think that
is kind of replicating now and then with
the punk rock and I mean I that was like
that my first love was you know music I
three older sisters so I got into music
you know a fairly early age and then
when 76 or 77 rolled around it was like
I that just became my life that was all
I did was listen to and go to concerts
and I saw everybody when I was living in
Northern California what did you like
about it like the clash was a very
emotional left-wing band but I didn't
really know the I didn't know what he
was really saying but I could I could
recite all the lyrics but not exactly
know what he's talking about in the
course of Sex Pistols were just
frightening people when you're like 16
and the Ramones were frightened they
were all frightening and I think that's
what made it like I just I thought these
guys are like in three minutes doing
amazing crazy stuff so that's what
that's what kind of you know I guess
that's what did it and I just and they
were melodic I guess new hostess I think
punk got maligned it was just basic
melodic pop songs turned out the
Buzzcocks you know that's a girl group I
know in some ways and the Ramones are
essentially doing girl group songs a lot
of ways yeah yeah the Sex Pistols oh
he's odd when yeah I remember hearing
that and being like oh yeah that it's
noise and it's beautiful noise but it no
actually it's like Beatles and fetus
yeah and you know I I got back into
misfits because they've been misfits are
massive fans of from red-eye to the GG
show and the vibe and so Jerry only was
came to the show and brought it brought
me cannolis he's a great guy he's the
bass player for missus he come over from
like Lodi New Jersey or whatever you
know there but like I'm listening so I
go back and I'm listening to static age
which is was an album from 78 but was
shelved is as good as good as any punk
album it's good but to somehow they just
couldn't get a deal and I realized that
misfits if they had gotten that deal
would have been as big as the Ramones or
the Damned
I think the melodies and Danzig's
singing is like really it was Elvis he
was Elvis in front of a punk band your
roots were in print journalism yeah do
you miss that do you miss obviously your
writing books and went up but and and is
print a print obviously isn't dead but
is are we in a new age of talk because
you're doing podcast as well as you I
knew you must talk like 32 hours a day I
do I do I can't shut up and I do you
could ask my staff I do talk to myself
which is like totally unnecessary like I
should be conserving that energy but I
will be muttering like I'll just be
muttering constantly and even and it's
like it's it's a very weird thing print
it's interesting because I like I'm
still writing but it ends up on blogs I
got a piece coming out this week on
social media mobs but there's some
things I don't miss and I work you
probably didn't run into this but in
when I was in I was in general Benz
magazine I at the pomposity and the
pretentiousness and the overpayment it
was I was all there in New York
publishing it was like oh gee cue our
competitors Esquire they you know they
were writing for other editors not for a
viewer not for readers and they were
just piling in the advertising dollars
but it was not like people were really
and that that world seems very dead I
mean you worked at Maxim yes and you
know which head into the ground that
wasn't good but I mean then Felix Dennis
the publisher I worked for a version I
worked for him at the nadir of his
career I would like to think that
caused the nadir of his career but you
when he successfully he'd destroyed
men's magazines by coming up with lad
magazine yeah yeah it was he saw it and
ran with it but it was loaded
you never loaded James Brown's and I
ended up working for James Brown for a
great magazine called Jack if you ever
find it it was like this big it's
amazing but anyway before that was
loaded loaded was the first it was kind
of came out of that kind of uh I guess
rave culture drug taking you know primal
scream music and and it was like that
was the punk that was these the finger
giving the finger to to GQ in to Esquire
and to arena those kinds of magazines
and then Maxim copied it but FHM copy
that and got huge in England but Maxim
got massive in the United States it was
like and that was a lot due to a lot of
you know mark Golan who was the real and
I think the the first editor to really
take this to a different level of like
humor it would says maximum wasn't
necessarily funny until Golan took it it
had an interesting sensibility in some
of the earlier Dennis publications of
where you were super fans but you made
fun of your idols yes and and that was
what was new and you saw that in ESPN
did that in sports and said I mean it's
a real cultural turn that I think caught
a lot of people unawares and we're still
in that if I look back I was talking to
a regular a regular guy a street sweeper
a baker a fireman Baker puts out fires
in the daytime and he bakes the best
bread no a person who was involved a
blogger who worked at Gawker and and
we're talking about like it's like right
the stuff I don't think you can do this
stuff that was done it in the my British
Maxim or in Steph magazine I don't think
you could do that stuff anymore I think
it's like we have changed what what is
defined as humor and now it's like humor
is only humorous if it doesn't offend
one person so there's a real danger like
if you if the jokes that I was making in
2000 right now even in men's health I
guess even the jokes back then would be
if in if there's one
states are not funny no they're gay well
some people don't have them yeah so the
assumption of doing you know that's yeah
you're already lose me I don't stay
Phantom syndrome but it is do you have
to be really really careful now about
the it's amazing one person can be can
guarantee anything you say you ended up
being fired right for a a gag a stunt
that was kind of legendary in the day
rehearsed that for us I was asked to
speak at a conference on how to create
buzz for magazines and it featured the
editors of Rolling Stone and oh and I
think glamour and something the
conference people would be up on a dais
and tell you how to create buzz for your
magazine they called me I was at stuff
which was the sister publication of
Maxim I said screw you I don't need to
do this and I hung up and then I heard
that they hired keep Blanchard from
Maxim to sit in for me and I'm going boy
I screwed up didn't I and I started
thinking about it and I go there's I I
called him up and I buy three tickets to
be in the audience and then I called my
friend Jeffrey Beecher who used to run
comedy madhouse which I think now is in
Vegas and he can get anybody in anything
and I said hey I could you locate three
little people for me and he goes win
because he that's he could it so it was
like by Thursday or whatever it was yeah
I got it no problem
I just just pay 100 each and that that
was it so then I had to go to LA to do a
stuff for a photo shoot with Pam
Anderson bill Schultz is at the buzz
that that the event so he's kind of like
the little person manager and so they
show up once dressed as a gangster once
dressed as a professor and I think once
dressed as a British person though I
can't remember with a cane and a monocle
but they had clipboards and so they sat
in various parts of the auditorium and I
don't even know how big it was but so
the people start talking and all of a
sudden their phones are vibrating and
they're vibrating on a clipboard so you
hear this
so the creating buzz so the thing is I'm
3,000 miles away or whatever and I'm
creating buzz in a thing about buzz so
what happened was they entered the
auditorium with clipboards and their
phones and so when their phones rang
they were on vibrate so they vibrated on
a clipboard
and so they're making buzzing noises so
in effect we were creating buzz in a
thin in a place that was purporting to
tell you how to create buzz and I wasn't
there so what happened was as this was
going on like one of the people what a
Cindy levy I think is her name said can
you please turn off your phone and and
one of them goes it's it's is it because
I'm short and so they were like they had
the armor that they could do this and
people were then a little bit scared and
so they kept in they were eating bags
and potato chips crunching I'd been
throwing questions out like why does
rolling stone suck was one of their
questions so finally people were turning
on Pete Blanchard because they thought
oh it had to be the maximum guy but it
was me and I was not around and Bill was
in the bill Schulz was in the goo ended
up I rang for a read I was in watching
everything and he said that there was at
one point some brave woman stood up and
said can't we just agree that there's
something going on here that this is
like we can't we're ignoring that
there's something happening and people
were like they finally got security I
think it was after 15 or 20 minutes had
to come in and take him out and and they
went outside and then I you know I get a
call from management not Felix but I
think with Steve Colvin who was the
president under him and he said Gregor
this event that went on and I go that
was I saw that was me and he goes that
was you and I go yes that was me it was
what did you tell me and I go but you
would have said no and he goes yes
you're right I would have said no and
then that was kind of it and I go it's
great it's like and it was in every
newspaper or it was like this is awesome
this is what stuff is supposed to do
we're supposed to create anarchy and and
pranks and and and and we created buzz I
showed them how to create buzz that was
the whole point but after a while it was
kind of like we've had enough of this
person he's becoming kind of a little
bit he's outgrown his job containment
you're a loose cannon yes I'm a loser
and so they promoted me it's a director
of brand development they gave me a
raise and they sent me to LA for a year
to stay on a trump-like get a wouldn't
get him away from the brand the epilogue
to the Gutfeld monologues is title this
is the end my friend yes explain that
literary allusion and
I should people I guess that was
allusion to Jim Morrison from the the
great song the end I guess I don't even
know if I was trying but maybe it's the
fact that I was just so Apocalypto tout
do you know what I mean
everything's the everyday is the end of
the day at the end of the world every
day at the end of the world and there
should I think the media should do a
correction every day that said yesterday
we told you it was the end of the world
we regret to inform you that it wasn't
and then they just keep going well we
are going to leave it there we have been
talking with Greg Gutfeld you can watch
him five days a week on the five you can
watch him once a week on the Greg
Gutfeld show and you can read his latest
book monologues
thanks so much Greg my pleasure NIC you
look great as always
they're terrible liar
[Laughter]